[Musique]
hallucinant
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui je suis à
bord du sam simon l'un des bateaux de
l'eau et jesse shepherd qui sont en
train de mener des opérations au large
des côtes françaises pour alerter du
sort des dauphins qui sont en train de
se faire massacrer
c'est ce qu'on va vous expliquer dans
cette vidéo
c'est fou la iata et on voit tous les
bateaux des réseaux et des façades vasic
aventure perd tous les bateaux des
alentours
on va aller se renseigner en fait auprès
de capital du mois exactement parce que
pour l'instant je sais pas quel est le
mode opératoire en fait comment vous
recommencez l'opération vous reprenez un
cap
alors là en fait on observe sur sur lay
est ce qu'un système électronique
d'identification des navires donc les
navires de pêche doivent avoir cette
taille est sans doute donc nous ça nous
permet de savoir à quel endroit ils sont
après on connaît aussi maintenant les
zones où il pèche d'habitude donc on va
aller sur la même rôle que pour pouvoir
contrôler la remontée des filets durant
la nuit
comment ça se passe avec les chalutiers
vous avez droit ce qu'on fait avec les
chalutiers c'est qu'on reste un petit
peu à l'écart et après on en voit donc
nos bateaux rapides ou de nos deux
zodiac pour aller observer de près en
même temps sans les déranger dans l'eure
dans leur prêche pour eux voulaient pas
les déranger mais parce que c'est légal
enfin leurs activités de pêche et légal
donc nous nous on est là vraiment pour
observer pour voir ce qu'ils font et
pour alerter les gens et l'opinion
publique sur ce qui se passe et on est
la seule présence en fait sur la côte
ouest et dans le golfe de gascogne pour
pour monitorer ce qui se passe donc donc
oui c'est une campagne importante parce
que personne d'autre n'est là
[Musique]
ça y est on a levé l'ancré là on part en
mer et voilà le but c'est vraiment
d'aller approcher les chalutiers qui
sont en train de pêcher et généralement
c'est plutôt de nuit que ce que les
opérations se déroulent que l'action
commence mes dents du matin on s'est
levés ya à peine dix minutes
on attaque maintenant
opération commence
tiens
[Musique]
à
ça c'est la manoeuvre classique pour mal
des bateaux à l'eau et après nous
passagers on va passer par une petite
échelle
le bateau par le côté
[Musique]
faut pas se rater
ouille ça bouge pas
simplement du pad off
les chalutiers commence à voir les
lumières
on vient d'arriver juste à côté qui
essayent année les bateaux sont à côté
de nous
pour bien vous expliquer les deux
bateaux là et sont côte à côte
c'est ce qu'on appelle dans le langage
maritime en boeufs et ensemble tire un
énorme filet qu'on appelle belgique
parce qu'ils évoluent tout seul dans
l'eau son touché le fond en forme d'auto
noir pour attraper des poissons
le problème c'est que le dauphin il va
s'approcher des filets il va être
curieux et c'est là qu'il se prend dans
les filets parce qu'il veut chasser il
va pas faire la différence ou il va
complètement être attiré par les
poissons
alors qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant
en fait voilà ils sont en train de
chahuter donc on va attendre que les
deux bateaux se rapproche il pêche
ensemble en fait pour pouvoir couvrir un
espace avec le filet donc on reste en
stationnaire ici pendant deux trois
heures et on observe ce qui se passe des
fois on peut rester on est d'ailleurs
resté huit heures c'est pas vraiment pas
tout le temps en fait toutes les règles
sont en train de nous observer une
longueur d'un petit peu ils savent qu'on
est là en plus la lumière de la caméra
et la lys à ce qu'on est là cela nous a
insultés dans le passé et consommant le
faire ce soir mais quand ils vont me
donner le sourire ils vont essayer de
chasser aussi pour essayer de pousser
comme ça s'il ya quelque chose dans le
filet il espère qu'on ne verra pas ça
marche parce qu'on est plus rapide que
est beaucoup plus maniable
maintenant c'est la phase d'observation
la phase d'attenté on va attendre à peu
près deux heures
et ça c'est le minimum ça peut aller
encore plus le temps qui remontent les
files
ça fait à peu près deux heures du matin
le filet nous tuons pas remonter
comment ça fait un peu froid
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il fait là il
une manoeuvre bizarre le deuxième
relever ils sont en train de relever les
niveaux
ok il est en train de chasser le
deuxième jeu diack de sea shepherd ils
foncent dessus
[Musique]
c'est hyper dangereux comme un oeuf ça
là en dix minutes tout la situation se
retourne avec les chalutiers qui
commence à chasser des bateaux de sea
shepherd est vraiment en mode rien à
[ __ ] toi il nous foncent dessus
c'est assez impressionnant une sorte de
tension [ __ ] c'est ouf
il remplit filet avec une énorme poulies
sur le bateau rattaché à plein de 4
dégueulasse [ __ ] c'est vraiment une
chimère
yann ça
c'est vraiment plein de câbles plein de
merdier je pensais pas que c'était aussi
gros et là ils ont pas encore fini de le
ramener à riz ça tire sur nous
une centaine de mètres facile facile
[ __ ]
tarik du film c'est infini mais
c'est nicolas
chaque monde qui travaille son frère
ben écoute
pas de pattes dauphin de requins l'autre
je pense qu'il va venir
au dessus
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
sarsgaard
c'était assez tendu parce que nous on
est tendu on veut pas voir les animaux
dans les filets
on est là pour regarder un pêcheur il
nous insulte mais voilà c'est pas
incroyable est en train de travailler il
faut pas non plus vous l'avez les gens
c'est pas aussi simple que ça
y'avait pas de faim mais surtout ce qui
m'a choqué c'est qu'avec aucun poisson
imagine que c'est fidèle à qu'ils sont
centaines de mètres sont laissé cinq six
heures dans l'eau
et à rien toutefois son père
on rentre à la maison
[Musique]
oui
à
je pense que les actions de chichey
perdre son super importante parce qu'il
faut des gens qui créent des pétitions
des gens qui sont plus calmes qui vont
plus faire des choses politiques mais il
faut aussi des gens qui sont sur le
terrain et qui fracasse quoi qui font
des choses que me font aujourd'hui ils
sont très calme ici sur cette mission
mais c'est important parce que ça fait
parler ça fait bouger c'est ultra
épuisant comme taf
ils sont tous bénévoles les mecs sont
sur des terres est vraiment il ya une
espèce de fraternité entre eux c'est
incroyable une famille et ils font ça
tous les jours tu vois depuis depuis un
mois pour certains donc c'est assez
violent
[Musique]
beaucoup entendu parler de la pêche
intensive mais je me rendais pas compte
c'est toujours la même chose c'est quand
tu vois devant toi que tu protèges une
prise de conscience je pense que le
problème c'est pas forcément les
pêcheurs peu il effectue juste les
besoins d'une demande c'est à dire de
nous citoyens qui compte ce monde de
plus en plus du poisson c'est peut-être
nous qui devons évoluer et adapter nos
méthodes de consommation et après en
découle évidemment tout ce qui est
industriel va peut-être se modifier et à
arrêter d'exister
pour nous il faudra interdire certaines
pratiques certaines techniques de pêche
parce qu'on sait qu'elles sont pas
sélective je pense qu'on a une époque où
les gens ont envie de savoir d'où
viennent les produits qu'ils consomment
les gens ne montrent de plus en plus de
traçabilité si on leur dit que le
poisson qu'ils achètent à tel endroit ou
tel type de poisson sa cause la mort de
dauphin il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
dire ben non mais je n'ai pas supporté
ce type de pêche parce que parce que
voilà je veux pas supporté que ça tue
des dauphins de rien maintenant on va
aller voir un organisme scientifique qui
s'appelle pélagie ce seuil qui ont tous
les chiffres et c'est eux qui ont tiré
la sonnette d'alerté par rapport à cette
problématique qui se trouve à la
rochelle donc on va repartir sur terre
et on va les rencontrer
[Musique]
bonjour on est dans une salle de topsy
là ces animaux on les a collecté en mars
là s'ils sont encore dans cet état là
c'est parce qu on les conserve
là on a des individus qui sont à peu
près de dix ans sur une espérance de vie
de 30 à 35 ans individus de bonne santé
de bonnes conditions physiques qui a des
hématomes des comptes nets des abrasions
donc une mort traumatique avec
l'apparence de contact filez donc voilà
ce qui permet de déterminer la mort
parra captures accidentelles ça c'est
notamment du filet de fileyeurs une
maille de milon qui est très fine quoi
très résistante aux 6 1 c'est à dire que
ça ça se ça se casse pas comme ça on va
faire de la mise en scène mais lorsque
on a un animal qui se retrouvent pris
sur une pectoral comme celle là ça tombe
pile poil la la maille exactement dans
la rainure et on voit bien que la
dimension de la maille correspond bien
gêné je l'avais pas fait ça comme
manipulation et c'est marrant comme
naturellement je dirais ça se met bien
en place enfin tous ces hématomes qu'on
voit ici et des hématomes qui sont liées
au contact filet bien proviennent en
fait de cet emprisonnement
donc ça c'est une preuve indéniable que
l'animal était vivant c'est vrai qu'à
filer pour y collecter une carcasse d'un
animal mort et là malheureusement les
animaux étaient vivants je pense que le
plus violent encore c'est la mort
agonique toute cette couleur là sont des
très gros hématome qui sont liés en fait
aux vaisseaux qui éclatent parce qu'ils
sont en train de s'asphyxier
et donc tout le poumon entièrement mêmes
déchirée par partie à l'intérieur
combien de temps il peut rester un
enfant souvent mis 20 30 minutes suivant
les espèces il ya des capacités qui sont
plus importantes après avec le stress
cette capacité là elle est réduite de
manière très importante
et pourquoi vous avez besoin de faire
une autopsie sachant qu'on est quasi
cieux on a des preuves défilèrent
vraiment pour pousser oui déjà c'est
pour avoir tous les éléments factuels
parce que notamment ce moment et
contester un petit peu nos diagnostics
et nous ce qui nous inquiète c'est que
ces populations soit pas maintenu dans
le temps je voulais les captures
accidentelles on connaît ça depuis les
années 80 en 2017
on a battu tous les records de la série
en termes d'effectifs en 2018
on a battu le record de 2017 et là alors
que la de saison je dirais 2
on a cette problématique de capture
n'est pas finie parce que c'est
quasiment fin avril début mai eh bien on
a déjà dépassé le record de l'année
dernière est très très largement combien
d'animaux vous avez depuis le début de
l'année alors nous on est une
comptabilité de 1200 animaux c'est à
dire que le nombre de morts en mer et
peut-être multiplier d'un facteur 5 et
là on pense que ces prélèvements ne
permettent pas à la population de se
maintenir sur le moyen ou long terme
les études démographiques des mondes
plutôt qu'on pourrait perdre cette
espèce dans le golfe de gascogne à
l'échelle de 50 ans avec les deux qui
sont sur la table entoure on en a neuf
de collectionner qui sont en attente
d'autopsié mois 11 en fait
gardez un move away ou les stocks à -11
pour qu'il soit bien conservé vous avez
eu que du dauphin oui non là il ya que
du dauphin il nous arrive d'avoir des
phoques de faire d autres petites
baleines aussi mais là sur le terrain on
les a même pas ici on véhicule tout ce
qu'on peut amener ici puis après tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pas être déplacés ont
l'effet sur le terrain derrière question
pour vous c'était comment vous voyez
l'avenir en fait simplement bas tout
simplement si on reste en l'état
l'avenir pour cet espace c'est très
inquiétant donc nous l'avenir
moi je le voudrais avec beaucoup
d'observation des pêches et on voudrait
simplement que on travaille ouvertement
avec la profession pour aussi les aider
à bien gérer leur milieu et ça bien ce
qui se passe à bord des bateaux iliad
nombre de marins qui savent ce qui se
passe quand nous ont dit les choses
eux ils savent qu'ils ont des maillets
du dauphin émis par dessus bord donc il
faut arrêter d'être dans le déni et faut
travailler ensemble pour le bien de tous
et qu'ont-ils mais on n'est pas encore
sûr cette tente là et c'est ce qui est
un peu inquiétant à vrai dire voilà